>> Tucker: A BAR IN PORTLAND
OREGON OFFERED REPARATIONS
HAPPY HOUR WHICH WHITE
PEOPLE WERE NOT ALLOWED TO
ATTEND BUT PAY FOR.
WHITE PEOPLE DID PAY FOR THE
NONWHITE PEOPLE WHO SHOWED
UP.
WHAT IS THIS ABOUT EXACTLY?
CAMMERON WHITMAN JOINS US TO
TELL US ABOUT IT.
HOW ARE YOU DOING.
>> HEY, TUCKER GOOD TO SEE
YOU AGAIN.
>> Tucker: NICE TO SEE YOU.
WHAT'S THE THINKING HERE?
>> SO, REPARATIONS HAPPY
HOUR IS AN EVENT, A
SUCCESSFUL EVENT THAT WAS
PUT ON MY NONPROFIT BROWN
HOPE.
FIND OUT MORE INFORMATION ON
BROWN HOPE.ORG.
40 BLACK, BROWN AND PEOPLE
WHO ATTENDED THIS EVENT, WE
HAD OVER 150 WHITE PEOPLE
DONATE.
AND THIS WASN'T ABOUT
ALCOHOL.
I HAVE BEEN SOBER FOR 27
YEARS.
SO YOU CAN TRUST I WAS NOT
PUTTING ON ALCOHOLIC EVENT.
WE BUILT COMMUNITY AND WE
MADE A SPACE TO HEAL FROM
THE IMPACT OF RACISM.
AND I BELIEVE THAT YOU AS A
CONSERVATIVE CAN RESPECT THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE PEOPLE
VOLUNTARILY SUPPORT THIS
EVENT AND SHOW THAT, YES,
INDIVIDUALS CAN TAKE ACTION
TO HEAL FROM THE IMPACTS OF
RACISM.
>> Tucker: IT'S A LITTLE AT
PATRONIZING THOUGH NO IN THE
ASSUMPTION ALL BLACK PEOPLE
ARE POOR AND NEED THE HELP
THE WHITE PEOPLE.
AND IT IT MAKES THE WHITE
PEOPLE FEEL VIRTUOUS LIKE
THEY ARE COMING TO THE
RESCUE AND I DON'T KNOW HOW
IT MAKES THE BLACK PEOPLE
FEEL.
BUT IT PROBABLY MAKES SOME
OF THEM FEEL PATRONIZED, I
WOULD THINK.
>> THANK YOU, TUCKER.
I SAW YOUR SHOW ABOUT
RACISM, ROSEANNE BAR WE BOTH
AGREE THAT RACISM IS REAL.
WE BOTH AGREE THAT RACISM
GOES TWO BASE.
AND WHAT WE ARE SAY
SOMETHING THAT RACIAL
DISPARITIES, IF YOU LOOK AT
OUR COUNTRY, THE COLOR OF
YOUR SKIN IS A PREDICTOR OF
HOW LONG YOU WILL LIVE, WHAT
KIND OF ECONOMIC LEVEL YOU
WILL BE IN AND OTHER
FACTORS.
AND SO WHAT WE ARE SAYING.
>> Tucker: CAMMERON, SOMEONE
WHO IS FAMILIAR WITH THE
NUMBERS IT'S NOT QUITE THAT
SIMPLE.
BROADLY, MAYBE.
AFRICAN IMMIGRANTS TO THIS
COUNTRY HAVE HIGHER LEVEL
INCOME LEVELS THAN POOR
WHITE AMERICANS.
IT'S NOT QUITE AS.
>> BLACK AND WHITE AS YOU
ARE SUGGESTING.
I GUESS THAT'S PART OF THE
POINT I'M MAKING.
NOT ALL BLACK PEOPLE ARE THE
SAME NOT ALL WHITE PEOPLE
ARE THE SAME.
THEY HAVE DIFFERENT
ATTITUDES AND INCOME LEVELS.
>> YEAH.
>> Tucker: THIS SUGGESTS YOU
ARE YOU ARE SUGGESTING
CERTAIN COLOR ONE CATEGORY.
ANOTHER COLOR ANOTHER
CATEGORY.
THAT MAKES ME UNCOMFORTABLE.
WHY DOESN'T THAT MAKE YOU
UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> WE ARE SAYING RACISM IS
REAL AND RACIAL DISPARITY
EXISTS.
WE ARE CALLING ON FOLKS FROM
A PRIVILEGED DEMOGRAPHIC TO
PAY INTO A SOLUTION AND
INVEST IN THE LEADERSHIP OF
BLACK, BROWN AND INDIGENOUS
PEOPLE WE CARE ABOUT THE
FACTS.
AND THE FACTS STATE THAT
RACIAL DISPARATE EXISTS AND
BROWN HOPE IS OFFERED
SOLUTIONS.
>> Tucker: LET ME ASK YOU.
>> IMPACTS RACISM.
>> Tucker: I THINK IT'S A
VERY CLEVER DEAL YOU GOT
GOING.
PAY FOR MY AND EVERYTHING
WILL BE FINE.
>> I AM CLEVER.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE
ENTREPRENEUR IN A HILARIOUS
WAY.
WHO WOULD.
>> WHO WOULD HAVE THOUGHT A
TINY EVENT ALREADY HAPPENED
ON PORTLAND NOW I'M ON FOX
NEWS AND NOW "NEW YORK
TIMES" IS COVERING IT WE
ELEVATED REPARATIONS.
>> Tucker: LET ME ASK YOU
THIS, WOULD IT MAKE YOU
UNCOMFORTABLE IF SOMEONE WHO
MADE LESS THAN YOU DID PAID
FOR YOUR MEAL OR YOUR DRINKS
BECAUSE YOU WERE A DIFFERENT
COLOR?
WOULD THAT MAKE YOU FEEL
UNCOMFORTABLE?
>> SO WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
IS THE REAL WEALTH DISPARITY
IN OUR COUNTRY AND WE KNOW
THAT THE WEALTH DISPARITY
BETWEEN BLACK'S AND WHITES
IS AROUND 10 TO 1.
SO WE KNOW.
>> Tucker: NO, THAT'S NOT --
NO, NO, THAT'S NOT --
SPEAKING IN GENERAL TERMS.
I ALREADY GAVE YOU ONE OF MY
COUNTER FACTS IS AFRICAN
IMMIGRANTS MAKE MORE THAN
WHITE AMERICANS ON AVERAGE.
>> ARE YOU COMFORTABLE
TALKING ABOUT THE REALITIES
OF THIS COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: GENERAL TERMS.
>> THAT AT THIS TIME
PARTICULARS.
YOU SEEM UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> Tucker: I'M AMUSED.
BUT, LET ME ASK YOU THIS.
>> ME TOO.
>> Tucker: DOES IT MAKE YOU
UNCOMFORTABLE TO GENERALIZE
ON THE BASIS OF RACE IN THE
WAY THAT YOU ARE, DESPITE
THE FACT THAT YOU ARE MAKING
MONEY FROM IT, WHICH AGAIN,
AS A CAPITALIST I APPLAUD.
IT'S AN AMAZING SCAM.
>> IT'S NOT A SCAM.
>> Tucker: IT.
>> EVEN LOOKING AT THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT.
WE SAW THAT RACIAL
DISPARITIES EXISTED AND BE
LIKE OH, GENERALLY SOME
PEOPLE IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS
ERA WERE DOCTORS.
SOME PEOPLE COULD VOTE.
WE HAVE ALWAYS HAD
EXCEPTIONALISM.
IN THE GENERAL FACT, LOOK AT
THE FACTS.
THE FACTS MATTER AND WE KNOW
THAT RACIAL DISPARATE.
>> Tucker: SO EMPOWERMENT
IS --
>> WE'RE WORKING WITH OUR
PARTNERS TO INVEST IN THIS
WORK.
WE WERE SUCCESSFUL.
>> Tucker: SEND ME A GUILT
OFFERING AND PAY FOR MY
DRINKS.
YOU ARE WINNING THIS GAME.
YOU ARE THE WINNER.
I LOVE THAT CAMMERON, IT'S
GREAT TO TELL YOU.
>> THE MAJORITY OF PEOPLE
WHO CAME WE GOT $10 IN CASH
FROM THE FOLKS.
HE
THEY SPENT THAT MONEY ON GAS
AND PAID FOR RENT FOR A
FRIEND IT'S NOT ABOUT
ALCOHOL.
WE CALLED IT HAPPY HOUR.
>> Tucker: YOU MADE MONEY.
CAMMERON.
THAT'S RIGHT.
>> WE ELEVATED REPARATIONS.
>> Tucker: GOOD JOB.
GOOD JOB.
UNFORTUNATELY WE ARE OUT OF